[Musique]
non ce ne sont pas les luminaires et les meubles qui font que les
personnes âgées vivent chez mes amis
non c'est comme vivre ici qu'est-ce que tu
veux dire tu connais tous les voisins qui
m'ont effrayé
ouais oh tu vis dedans
qu'en est-il de la famille qui vivait ici  ils ont
dit qu'ils avaient juste disparu alors ce qui
s'est passé je ne sais pas regarde c'est arrivé il y a
plus de 10 ans quelque chose se passe
et ça ne va pas
disparaissons c'est un déménagement oh je
veux une nouvelle serrure quel est le prix de la sécurité de ta
famille John
que je ne peux pas rester ici quoi que ce soit c'est
une super maison dans un super quartier Oh
toi